this is a production of Cornell
University
it's interesting when we compare notes
some of the things that heather has said
I'm going to say again and the reason
being is what we both found they are
critical steps in success with these
crops that's why we repeat them because
that's what we've been finding now
basically winter cover crops are really
a winter forages basically a cover crop
on steroids you get all the benefits and
then some why because as she said you
put some management into growing this
stuff you put some effort in it really
comes back to benefit you in multiple
ways you get all the soil nutrient
benefits and you get a return on your
checkbook that spring
with winter forages we're increasing our
yield per acre 25 to 35 percent getting
six to ten tons a very high quality feed
early when we had the drought in 16 a
lot of people put it in because they
needed feed early in the next spring and
that gave them the earliest feed it
produces forage for the high and fresh
cows we can all make heifer feed we can
all make low Kathy you can't always make
that creampuff stuff for the high cows
this is for the high cows and I've got a
number of farmers who have told me they
grow it specifically to feed in the
summer because one day heat turns on and
the cows lump they put that in the diet
there is no slump the cows keep milking
right on through and dick grant up at
miner Institute said that's because of
the very high end DFT digestibility of
this stuff they can digest that fiber
without producing a lot of heat so they
keep on milking so guys grow it
specifically for the high cows and they
get all the benefits of a cover crop
while doing it if you put nitrogen on
and sulfur you need sulfur you're gonna
get crude protein equal or beating a lot
of the legumes 20% you're going to have
an energy level taking that flag leaf
stage you'll have an energy level within
that energy of lactation equaling what a
lot of corn silage is have and if you
look at the TPN BFD the total tract and
the F digestibility corn silage average
corn silage or alpha average alfalfa is
42 good stuff is 48 and this stuff is 66
really good feed guys have started
growing this now comeback and they grow
it again and again again because of the
milk you can get out of this
now the economics on it economics are
driven a lot by yield it runs between
seven tenths of a tonne per acre to two
tons per acre two tons per acre is worst
case scenario you need a shot of
nitrogen in there and one ton dry matter
reduction in the corneal and I'll
explain why that occurs in a minute
we're gonna come up and this may this
appear especially based on work that
heather has been doing with these short
seeds and corn varieties that really
crank out the yield go look at her work
you could see short season varieties we
can grow that really pushed the yield
you don't always need a yield hit
optimum planting date for us where I am
I'm just south of Albany New York ten
days to two weeks before we that is the
500-pound gorilla in the room for yield
you need to get it in the ground as she
said ten days to two weeks before your
wheat planting date my wheat planting
date is September 20th ten days before
that I need to have this in the ground
September 5th or September 10th but we
need to get the corn off then to do that
by not planting it early by planting it
in October because that's when we put
cover crops on right well there goes 20%
of our yield right off the top it's gone
because you need those early heat units
to drive the tillering as she said you
get nine tillers instead of a one or two
tillers so if you were gonna plant late
and add more seed and seed guys like the
Celje to do you're going to have to put
450 pounds of seed out there to get the
same yield which is ridiculous you need
to get it in on time
now bill Cox's work found that there was
3/4 of a ton of silage lost for every
five-day shorter season corn on average
but with Heather and Joe Lawrence's work
where they can see that these shorter
season varieties can crank out the yield
I had one this year an 82 day variety
gave me 30 tons to the acre but we're
going to take this as an assumption and
if we go from 105 day to an 85 day so we
can get our triticale planted sooner or
our where I planted sooner we're going
to give up a ton of dry matter which is
about 3700 80 pounds of milk we're
replacing it with two to four times a
dry matter of winter forage and we're
now gaining 8,000 to 16,000 pounds of
milk per acre for 3700 we gave up on the
corn go back and look at her short
season corn data by shortening up the
corn you're not going to be losing yield
if you double crop and the important
part is is we may not even lose yield
with some of these shorter season
varieties
this is a more graphic example if we did
assume that to reach on yield this is
what it looks like if we put in a single
long season 20 tonne to the acre versus
17 with a double crop but then when you
put on a minimum double crop or an
optimum bubble crop we get higher yields
and I could explain some of those pieces
why it has to do some work with their
climate zone but the bottom line is is
now we are getting more yield than with
a full season crop and you're not out
there in November chopping corn silage
if you're out there in November cut
chopping corn silage you are packing the
snot out of that ground and you're
getting long-term yield reduction get
your corn off on the ground is dry
get your triticale in and then you could
take off and keep going
if we remove the residue it makes it
easier to plant the next crop now there
is a problem with some of this and that
is called allelopathy and I was that's
what I had brought up with sorrow who
talked just before lunch
allelopathy is real it will inhibit
grass crops growing next corn sorghum
death can be inhibited by having winter
grain residue there in the ground we get
around it by using strip till I sent
this in I had another picture of what we
use basically it's a clearing Coulter
that has a little like knives on it and
it scrapes the top half inch or inch of
dirt away it removes that allelopathy
from the plant you plant it into clean
ground and it pops up out of the ground
and grows with no problem whatsoever if
you don't do that you are going to be
taking somewhat of a yield loss they had
a 4 ton yield loss at miner Institute
where they planted right into Rye well a
lot of that was allele opacity just
inhibiting the plant you scraped that
aside you can use your no-till planter
plant right into it this is going to
allow air in water to move in for clay
soils this is huge because clay soils
seal over like this countertop on the
first rain air and water can't go in and
out when it rains it all washes off and
takes the soil with it the bridge ends
clays are perfect for that kind of stuff
for sealing over but if your planting
into this all those stems have a root
going down into the ground allows air
and water in and out
okay if we have a lilo pathy it's sort
of like getting lemons you know God gave
you lemons so what do you do you make
lemonade all right we have a lilo path
it keeps weeds from growing
lambsquarters pigweed ragweed all those
keeps from growing
it keeps the corn crop from growing it
keeps the sorghum crop from growing it
doesn't affect legumes so we said well
duh normally people don't like to put in
legumes very often they don't like to
rotate why because they only get a half
a crop seeding year and so then the
second year you get full year and that
yield and then you'll start to come off
over time afterwards so we don't want to
see down and take a half a crop you have
an option you grow winter forage you
take off two to four tons of dry matter
come back in and they'll tell your
alfalfa into it getting one cutting of
alfalfa and the total yield that year is
equal to your full years you never take
a yield loss you now get a full yield on
that year and added benefit on that is
first of all the wind stays up and off
of it
some guys found that this late last year
when it was really dry they planted
their raw alfalfa no-till into triticale
stubble and it still grew it kept that
drying wind off of those little plants
they could get established
they took off and grew it works with
alfalfa red clover and soybeans it works
very well no tilling it in it reduces
seeding risks as I just pointed out an
increase is seeding year yield which I
just mentioned a minute ago
you've got your total yield stops
erosion loss
I had a farmer call me up here about
about in July or August and he said I
put in five six hundred acres of alfalfa
this year plowed it all up smooth it all
up planted alfalfa on the whole thing I
had a hundred and fifty acres of
triticale I motored off and I no tilled
alfalfa and this year we had a lot of
gully washers downpours he had it in
June he got
hammer he says I've got 5 to 600 acres
of gullies rocks and no seeding because
the fields washed out and I have a
hundred and fifty acres of creampuff
alfalfa
that's doing just fine thank you this
question to me was does it justify the
cost of a new no-till drill so I gave
them the names of a couple people to
talk to he never talked to him I think
he just wanted a reality check he went
out and bought the no-till drill he's
doing all his leggings this way and the
other benefit that happens on big farms
it inhibits weeds I mentioned it moves
the workload the first nice week the
first nice day in April you're a week
behind second nice day in April you're
two weeks behind isn't it the way the
workload usually goes you're trying to
get seedings in your ground work table
stones planted and spread manure and get
that ground worked up so you can plant
corn all at the same time we take all
the seedings and we move them right out
of there come springtime you spread your
manure you plant your corn come in
harvest your triticale or rye take it
off go get your grass fields triticale
comes off just before the cool season
grasses so you take your triticale you
take your cool season grasses then go to
your alfalfa grass mixes finish up with
good alfalfa now it's beginning of June
come back in that field spray it with a
quart of roundup and accorded to for
just a cord around him I'm sorry a
quarter roundup or less I've used a half
cord around them and a high gallonage of
water 17 18 gallons yet here you hose it
down because there's a lot of little
shoots in plants coming up you wipe them
out come back in with your no-till
planter this field had no post merchant
herbicide that's what it looks like
pretty good
it will grow very well this has been a
huge sleeper in winter forages that few
people have realized works and it works
really well
now managing this for forage you have to
management's had there touched on this
you have a fall nitrogen management and
you have a spring nitrogen management
and there are two very different pieces
but they are interrelated
Sarah's talk just before lunch here
today was right in the the ballroom was
right on target with terms of tying up
nitrogen from the fall keeping it out of
the water the biomass that you have is
the most important factor it is driven
by planting date nitrogen stored is
driven by biomass times the planting
date 62 pounds of nitrogen we picked up
after a corn crop if we planted a late
we picked up four pounds where did the
60 pounds go into the water supply or
denied Rifai neither which is good both
our losses to the farm ones a pollutant
but if we plant this on time we're gonna
pick up 60 pounds of nitrogen now we
have taken this a little bit further
you'll see in a minute the benefits that
you get from cover crops or winter
forage accrue according to the biomass
produced this is planted September 9th
this is planted October 6th this is
going to be not needing any herbicides
this will need a herbicide because
there'll be weeds in it this is tying up
the nitrogen adding organic matter the
roots are going deeper adding soil
structure soil health and producing
those tillers Heather had talked about
that give you the yield potential for
the next year all of this because you
get it in on time on time is very
critical
and then dr. Kettering's and myself have
both come up with a similar graph here
in our data's our researches each which
is as your biomass goes up the pounds of
nitrogen stored goes up and I did find
out Q that mine didn't have a higher
nitrogen didn't have a higher line with
manure it was the exact same line no
difference that's something new I just
figured out yesterday what what we did
is we said all right if this will tie up
nitrogen what if I put some manure on in
the fall because my previous work any
time with what nitrogen on in the fall
I got a yield increase across all
nitrogen levels the next year so I said
well I don't want to buy fertilizer and
we all got manure we need to unload
where are we going to go with it what if
we put some on the ground so we came in
and we put 4,000 gallons on incorporate
it right away and plant it we came in in
October put 4,000 on incorporated and
planted at the end in November we had
123 pounds of nitrogen stored in the
above-ground material
in the October one we had four pounds of
nitrogen everything was still in the
soil and much of that was gone by spring
they had converted over to nitrate so we
have another piece going on here where
we're looking at putting that manure and
we have a new injector it's just been
built it's in Iowa right now they're
trying to get a truck to haul it here
and we're gonna try coming in and mid
November and injecting right into the
sod of the winter forage manure so we
don't need nitrogen in the spring so you
put it in late it's the ammonia form
it's gonna stay there till spring and it
warms up it's going to convert to
nitrate but as soon as it warms up the
grasses the winter forage is already
growing and it's gonna suck it right up
so remember I said 75 pounds of nitrogen
we had a higher nitrogen higher tons of
dry matter to break even we think we can
drop that so we don't need anything in
the spring yes I am using instinct with
it but we don't know whether it pays or
not we're still working on that my
problem is is the the research is on a
farm that Cornell is selling tomorrow
and I've got a sweet talk whoever buys
it to let me finish my work so it's
we're on tender hooks until tomorrow
I'll tell you the answer tomorrow all
right if we put manure on in the fall
the following spring we got 14% higher
yield where we had put it on versus not
putting manure on where are we doing in
October we had 33% higher yield I
remember there is still looks back that
up there is still a significant portion
of that nitrogen is lost because you
don't have enough biomass to tie it up
and store it in the crop that is the
critical piece this is an
environmentally sound program this I
have real reservations on in terms of
polluting the water supply
top dressing it in the spring I do not
recommend top dressing it in the spring
if you've done a good job planting this
in the fall this is what it looks like
you spread manure on that it's going to
get into the crowd and I have one farm
they refuse to admit anything but I
understand why because it's a complete
embarrassment put manure on
chop the stuff off put it into silo when
they started to feed the bunk out they
hit it with the loader and the whole
pile slid down in a slimy maggot filled
mess you don't want to feed that to the
cows they insisted on it
screw the cows up royally making things
even worse
I don't recommend putting manure on the
top of any of this there is some
possibilities for injection we are
working on that as I go right now
hopefully we'll be able to continue the
research on it all right yes yes we're
gonna probably do it just before
Thanksgiving surface application problem
comes back to this we get it mixed into
those crowns this this is this was taken
last week that's what my winter forage
looks like going in another one just
putting it on top of that it's going to
get into the crowns and it's going to be
there in spring and that's where you
could get into real troubles that's why
we're looking at an injector that will
slice through put it into the ground so
we don't have the problem if that works
we could theoretically come in in March
when the ground has maybe a little bit
of frost left in it and put that in then
we don't know we're way out on a limb on
this my concern would be we're expecting
a lot of rain this winter two-hundred
percent of normal precipitation we're
supposed to be warmer than normal and if
rain is leeching through this and the
ground is frozen then it's still running
off in the water that's my concern
there's some real hesitancies in here
you got to be be careful we don't know
all the answers I'm just telling you
where we're going with the research okay
as Heather said before stage of growth
is a bigger effect than the species of
grain chose them this is stage 8 at
stage 8 it's not ready yet the leaf is
still rolled up in the stem here coming
out you're not getting full yield this
is stage 9 the leaf last leaf is out and
the head is in here this is what we hit
for high quality winter for it whether
it's rye wheat or barley or triticale
this is what we hit right here
now I had stage 8 on a Thursday I had
stage 9 on a Friday I mean on a Tuesday
rather from Thursday to Tuesday and in
that timeframe we had a 35% yield
increase if I could give you something
to put on to get a 35 percent yield
increase you jump on it but in this case
you built the factory let it produce let
it produce until you get to here now
this is stage 10 that's boot stage when
we were at 12,000 pounds of milk per cow
that was fine but we're at 30,000 pounds
of milk per cow this is where we need to
be is that stage 9
that being said a couple of pieces first
Jeff's work showed that triticale the
red line here loses quality at a slower
rate than as wheat or rye the other
piece is what is the temperature of the
year you're doing this
2010 it was a normal to warm spring as
it went down here's a like either this
one or this one this flag leaf stage
quality's going down as time went on all
right this is digestibility Katy Reaper
our
2013 we were at flag leaf stage this is
actually boot stage year flag leaf boot
and headed out and it's still real
high-quality why it was cold 2013 two
hours north of us they had three feet of
snow it was down to freezing or just
above freezing that night so if it's
that cold you don't have to rush quite
as much you have a bigger window to get
things done unfortunately usually when
it's cold like that it's also damp and
rainy and you can't always get out there
so it doesn't always work all right it
rains for three weeks the stuff is all
headed out what am I going to do with it
well first of all is a lot of foreign
speed straw so you could chop this stuff
that's head straw and you put it in your
TMR the other is at Lake mood through
early milk stage it's intermediate on
protein moderate on energy digestibility
will not inhibit intake for good heifer
growth without the heifers getting fact
it makes an excellent heifer feed I have
one farm that grows this for their dry
cows they don't put any manure on that
field they draw it grow it for dry cows
if I grow red clover and tried to kale
the middle of June I'm pulling off 21
tons to the acre of 35% dry matter
material if I go just triticale I pulled
off 16 almost 17 the farmer says he gets
consistently 18 tons to the acre now I
would not use red clover I would use
medium red red clover heads out too soon
and then at the terior h real fast
medium red keeps right on growing and
could produce a lot more yield you look
at the dry matters that stuff is bowrekt
to a windrow and go ahead and chop it
now if you're doing at stage 9 and
you're doing for the milk cows do not
mow it to a narrow windrow you need to
use wide swaths same day haylage to get
that quality in the sugar runs 20
percent 1 year ran 26 percent the guys I
was doing the work with said we can't
use your data nobody's gonna believe us
as 26 percent sugar sunny days cold
nights it'll produce the sugar and as
one farmer said he started worrying
about the cows because when they pulled
up with a wagon the mixer wagon with
this stuff in it he said all the cows
jump up and come running over to so I
said well long as they're doing that I
wouldn't worry about it they start
rolling to have her start rolling it and
smoking and out back of the barn you can
probably work high yield 6 to 14 tons
the acre two to three times what alfalfa
will yield so that means your management
for harvesting stuff has to be a little
different here the guy was mowing it
thought he was doing a really good job
60% I cut her bar width you need to be
more than 80% of cut her barn well what
we did is we stopped them we opened up
the shields in the front of the Machine
yes he was driving on it but now we are
at 80% of cutter bar with the second
piece is mowing with these shields down
the lawyer shields down versus up when
we mow when it down what happens is it
comes up it hits it and drops it in a
lump and lumps don't dry this is Curtis
Martin in Savannah he was measuring
every two feet was a pile and the piles
don't dry he opened it up so it flows
right through and out the back it
spreads it uniformly
it's going to dry a whole lot faster
here's the lumps all the way up through
and down and over hook back up this year
we opened up the back of the machine and
you can see the difference in the past
it lays it out loose fluffy turn them
let air through it and let it dry but no
matter what you do as one farmer said if
I grow this right and I'm pulling off
three and a half tons of dry matter it
goes out the back of the Machine and it
goes splat and it dries on the outer
three-quarters of an inch and the rest
sits there
two hours after mowing we recommend you
come in with a cheddar and Ted it lift
and spread it all right it had spread
out you've got to watch your forward
speed otherwise you make tedder lumps
that machine can go faster than it can
handle the tonnage remember this is two
to three times more than alfalfa and you
go whaling through there with the
tractor it's gonna go but it's going to
grab big hunks pack them together and
throw them out the back of the machine
you need to watch your forward speed
keep the RPMs up the Watchers forward
speed so it can pull it apart I don't
own stock in the company but every
farmer I know who has bought of the MIR
hook time Tedder says it's a different
machine it works very well to do stuff
like this it really pulls it apart
throws a green on the top and the dry on
the bottom
they said it's fascinating the work it
works very well but you do need to Ted
it so harvest you want to mow it wide
80% of cutter bar with ten today after
two hours of drying if your machine is
not putting at a eighty percent then
when you get done mowing the field go in
with the Tedder and tent it out chop it
longer an inch or more we chop BM our
corn why we chop it long because if we
don't it falls apart and flushes out of
the room and before you get the extent
of digestion that you want this stuff
will digest faster than BMR corn will so
you need the longer particles and the
longer particles are less likely to
juice if you don't get it dry enough the
longer the particles are less juicing is
going on you want to insulate the same
day as you mow it unless it goes down
below 40 degrees if it's below 40 at
night down into the 30s you can hold it
overnight you're going to be alright the
temperatures are cold enough otherwise
you need to get it in the same day you
mow it and then use a homo lactic type
bacteria to get those high sugars the
ferment at 24 hours 48 hours it's cold
questions wide
in about five minutes yes I'm back and
forth on that because I had a study
where it was planted early 120 pounds of
nitrogen planted October 120 pounds of
nitrogen planted October no nitrogen the
dead stuff went right on in overall
three that's where the water set in
March when the ground started the thon
you have those virgin clays and you get
these ponds out there in March the snows
melting and you get these big Blake's
and apply in spots you don't expect them
snow mold comes through and really
hammers it at that point
did you get any icing all right I
haven't run into that Sara ran into it
with hers I haven't run into it but the
icing could be a big factor yeah I'll
find out this year because I've got some
stuff that's I think I have two and a
half tons a dry matter out there and I
had 8,000 gallons of manure before I
planted it that's experiment and so that
is set up to get really nail we get the
right conditions we'll see what it does
but the flipside is when we get it
canopy like that if it doesn't SH mush
yes you guys get feet of snow if it
doesn't SH Moore's down then it actually
protects the crowns from the cold so it
can help the other possibility you know
knowing where you're from
there it's probably the wooly mammoths
or mastodons trampled it that's she'll
back over me in the parking lot for that
one I have serious reservations about
the varieties you're growing now those
okay the other piece that comes in I
didn't put it in this talk acai had a
limited amount of time you need to get
it in especially in your area with your
heavier soils and colder temperatures it
needs to be an inch and a quarter in the
ground if it's not an inch and a quarter
what happens in the springtime freezing
at all it'll pop it up a half-inch
that's all it takes
and then the air dries those roots and
the plant sits there is this little
green stub it never grows and I said
winter kill no you didn't get it in the
ground it was a hardware issue the loose
knot at the steering wheel didn't plant
it deep enough you need to get it in the
ground I made that mistake early on I
didn't get a shallow I didn't get it
deep enough and I got royally screwed
because it died on me and up in the
north we put our varieties up north
we're looking at moving our variety
trial now with the Willsboro they got to
get it in an inch and a quarter in the
ground at least so what dozen Heath
that's another piece but ice sheeting
and packing down I haven't experienced
that in 18 years of doing it doesn't
mean it doesn't happen it can still
happen
yes that's what I did that works right
anyway yeah that works very well no not
when it's growing on the top yeah no no
just such a plain your alfalfa earlier
and you'll get that's the other thing
you guys can get five tons of dry matter
six tons of dry matter off your
triticale I'm doing good to get three
she's doing good to get two because as
you move north it gets tougher and
tougher because you got to plant it
earlier and earlier I'm pretty soon I
work with some guys up in Lacombe which
is two hours north of Calgary you can't
see polar bears from there but they're
just around the corner and they are
growing a sixty-day corn it takes 90
days to get it mature but they're
planting all their triticale in the
round the 15th of august they got to get
it in early enough to get the tillering
to get the growth on it to get the yield
and make it through the winter but you
have a higher yield potential than I do
because I used to live down a quarry
built and we have that long fall and
that long spring there you have a lot
more yield potential than I do
you know we got I had a picture I sent
Sara it's um
a guy in 2016 planted corn after his
triticale and he has a what was she a
six month old and maybe a two year old
standing next to his corn and his corn
was tasseled and it was as high as the
two year old which is about this high
but he said his neighbor's wasn't any
better and he has a whole barn for bunk
full of triticale so he did or right he
says it was fine and he's going to do it
again it will dry the ground if you have
heavy ground like Heather fights with up
there all the time it helps to pump the
water out in the spring so it allows you
to get on but if it turns dry that is an
issue but interestingly the first year I
did that alfalfa I took it off put the
alfalfa in the beginning of June we had
one three-quarter inch rain about a week
after and then we had a quarter of an
inch of rain the third week in June and
we had nothing through July to the
middle of August Bill Smith looked at my
plot and September he says it looks like
a two-year-old stamp that's how well it
grew it really did well and some guys in
western New York tried it in 16 and they
were amazed at how well it worked right
through the dry a little bit of moisture
that air is kept off of it and they can
get started but yes it can get dry
enough that nothing grows it's not a
perfect system it can get wiped out then
I put stuff in and April and had to get
wiped out too yes you're not opening the
ground up and drying it and you have to
no-till it you open a slit and a press
wheel drill put it in don't try
broadcasting your seed or user a
brilliant cedar and then rolling it
afterwards you might as well just take
the seed and throw it in the bushes it
does not work then there does have done
that don't do it
[Music]
if it was that high and is a very good
chance that has already started sending
a seed head up
especially because beginning of
September we had some really cold
weather it may have got enough chilling
that had burn alized and it's now
sending a seed Hut up and it may not
make it through the winter simply
because it was planted way too early now
what we have done though is we've
planted the beginning of August we've
planted oats 100 pounds of oats 80
pounds of triticale and then we take the
old saw blade to manure in on it and
then take the oats off and the September
cut it four inches not shorter has to be
four inches and we got a couple of tons
of really night oast night's oats feed
and then all the true the kale started
growing after that we moved it we took a
tree to Cal crop off the next spring so
you can but if you get it too early and
it grows too long and it gets a chance
to burn alive
it's going to get killed out it will die
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu